dive anchor Trump has a new book of
business advice for women yeah yeah yeah
tip number one is be your rich dad's
favorite daughter please no I just say
it I'm good we have the dumbest show on
television but people in the audience
could you care for my nipple I'm good
for now thank you you left the guy's
nipple hanging out get to him later
right in the parking lot yeah technology
news Nissan Nissan is developing
technology that blocks cell phone
signals so people won't be distracted by
their smartphones that's great good idea
first first Nissan will put the
technology in their cars then they'll
put it in the oval office
so that way
the presidency there's a rumor that
Facebook founder Mark Zuckerberg is
planning to run for president Mark
Zuckerberg might run for president yeah
you must really want to win because
today's Zuckerberg sent Vladimir Putin a
friend request probably forget you there
you're clapping just a little too long
[Laughter]
James Comey testified about his
involvement in the last election he's
been testifying today FBI director James
Comey said the thought that he helped
Donald Trump get elected president makes
him mildly nauseous mildly nauseous yeah
call me then excused himself to attend a
meeting of under reactors anonymous you
may have changed the course of history
[Music]
I'm okay now yes it has the same effect
as a racetrack chili dog yeah had a
chili dog at the racetrack
well that's why speaking of food
speaking of food a company has come out
with a robot that makes salad yeah so
finally a robot that's not going to take
away any American jobs
thank you would you like something low
in calories and high in fiber in New
York a cocaine trafficking ring was
busted after they were caught pretending
to be Ober drivers yeah police called
uber the perfect cover for coke heads
because most Eber drivers also never
stopped talking so it's alright it's
true and then I got to mention this
yesterday in Florida a drunk and naked
man wielding a machete went on a rampage
attacking mailboxes Santori yeah
local police put out an APB for
literally any guy in Florida American
Airlines announced it's going to reduce
legroom in coach by two inches yeah yeah
the last time I heard someone complain
about 2 inches on American Airlines I
was trying to join the mile-high club
you like that one huh huh huh that's so
true to me that rang of the real yeah I
could see that well you don't want to
see it
you